the new Nintendo switch game console
hits stores this weekend giving gamers a
new way to ignore their loved ones at
home or on the go and I'm very excited
but Krusty critics have been slamming
the switch for its limited roster of
game titles like one - switch where you
can milk a cow and take care of a crying
baby listen I think that's fine finally
we have the technology to simulate being
a Kentucky teen mom you guys wanted that
or little inferno little inferno where
you can burn stuff in a virtual
fireplace sweetness I want you to give
us them even more a typical video games
other than the ones on the switch I'm
going to put 60 seconds on the clock and
begin
Natalie call it booty modern dating boys
Microsoft paint drying see super mario
batali brothers Lauren Lauren Grand
Theft Auto Zone waiting area yes boy
good Pete Star Fox News yeah now
gynecologist Marv across womb Raider oh
boy sweet home single dragon yeah
winners don't use drugs
Lauren lapkus call of jury duty yeah
fine Natalie
[Applause]